there is big news brewing in the
southern part of the united states the
governor of florida is confirming that
the state is working on a plan to allow
businesses to pay taxes in bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies now this is a huge huge
deal because what it is signaling is
that the state of florida believes that
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies not only
serve as a store of value but also as a
medium of exchange one that they would
be willing to accept for people to pay
those state taxes now i personally don't
think that a ton of people are gonna go
spend their bitcoin ethereum or any
other cryptocurrency what they are
likely to do though is pay in stable
coins that are on just much better
payment rails than anything in the
legacy financial system we've got a
quote here from governor desantis in
which he says i've told the state
agencies to figure out ways where if a
business wants to pay tax and
cryptocurrency to florida we should be
willing to accept that and we're working
through that now the state of florida is
not the first to try to do this the
state of ohio under treasurer josh
mandel already allowed businesses to pay
in bitcoin but once mandel left office
the next treasurer came in and they
rolled it right back something tells me
that the state of florida is serious and
they won't be ruling this back we've got
a tweet here from dan tapiro where he
states not sure what could be more of a
green light for institutions a u.s state
considering receiving taxes owed in
bitcoin remarkable to think that anyone
still owns the 200 trillion dollars in
cash and bonds with negative real yields
light bulb moment is coming i tend to
think that dan's on to something because
this is a signal this is a milestone
that many institutions will look at and
say well if it's good enough for a
united state to actually go ahead and
accept bitcoin or cryptocurrencies for
taxes maybe i should put in my portfolio
in the words of satoshi nakamoto maybe i
should get some just in case it catches
on now we've got another quote from ron
desantis the governor of florida in
which he states there's a difference
between decentralized digital currency
like bitcoin and what some are talking
about doing at the federal level to
convert us dollars into basically a
digital currency i think there's a lot
of hazards with that when that's
centrally controlled i worry about the
amount of power that that would give
someone an essential authority to
basically be able to shut off access to
purchasing certain goods we'd be in
unchartered territory the governor of
florida gets it bitcoin is different
than a central bank digital currency or
any other cryptocurrency out there it is
truly decentralized no one owns it no
one controls it that's a programmatic
monetary policy and it is telling the
state of florida they want bitcoin and
if they can't go buy it off of their
balance sheet maybe they'll just accept
it from businesses for taxes every state
in america is gonna end up doing this
it's the ones who do it early that will
benefit most hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time